الكثير من الأشياء إذا كنت بحاجة
للتخلص منها بقدر ما يمكنك البدء
في رميها هناك ، ابدأ في رميها
هناك وتوقف عن رميها هناك ، توقف عن
رميها هناك
[موسيقى]
لأن الكتاب المقدس يقول في ephesians
إلى  الأشخاص الأفيسيان في أعمال 19
أنهم أحضروا السحر والشعوذة وكتبهم
وهراءهم الخفي وقاموا بحرقه وزرعوا
كلمة الله بقوة ، لذلك أعلنا في
نهاية الأسبوع الماضي أننا سنحصل على
إنجيل قديم كبير يحترق ونحن
[موسيقى
] لم أعد العبث بالسحرة ،
لم أعد العبث بالسحر ، لن
أعبث مع الشياطين ، سأناديهم جميعًا
باسم يسوع المسيح ،
وسأطلق عليهم جميعًا
من الأفضل أن تحصل عليهم  تخلص من فوضى هاري بوتر
في منزلك ، والتي هي عبارة عن سحر كامل ،
إنها سحر
[موسيقى]
لدينا نوع من السحر يتهجى للجميع
كتب كل ما يمكن أن
تتخيله وها هو هذا الشيء ممتلئ ، لذلك لدينا
الكثير من الملابس إذا كنت بحاجة إلى ذلك
تخلص منه
يمكنك الحصول عليه مجرد نجمة  رميها
هناك ابدأ في رميها هناك ابدأ
برميها هناك